the next question is I heard a
ridiculous thing from a mate of mine
today that 70% of your GCSE grades have
to be in stars I've got twelve eight
stars five days and a B they just want
over six or seven eight stars at GCSE
not 70% of grades being stars right so I
know statistically the average medical
the average successful medical applicant
has seven a stars yeah
and that's probably the highest number
of a stars for any subject I'm gonna
guess that it yeah it's a statistic it's
not a requirement like they're never
going to specify what GCSEs you need so
I think yeah for medicine you say it's
like seven a star so many sure I think
it varies between like two and twelve or
something ridiculous eight stars but
there's no set number that you need to
get in and equally if you've got like a
few a stars and then the rest of you
gave groans and rubbish you know it's
like a they're going to take all into
account but the most important thing
will be your a-levels they use GCSE
results kind of in addition to that like
they might look at your a level results
and if you have similar results to
another candidate it might then look at
your GCSEs and see like how you compare
that but the gtas won't be as important
as you interview
as I said you a levels so no you don't
need 70% a stars I think the grades
you've got that look great
you'll be fine and also it's important
to note that even if you only have say
one or two a stars it's still it's not
like you should just give up on applying
yeah there are people here that you know
not even named names obviously the
people you definitely have not the
raising expect I'm not too sure and
they've gone on to do really well here
yeah and it's also context specific so
they may look at especially I don't know
if they do is for a levels but they do
as for GCSEs a look at how you performed
in relation to other people at your
school because this is what they'll have
a solid datum also with your a levels
are not going to have your concrete
grades are going to have your s levels
and your predicted grades
whereas GCSEs those will be like those
are the only actual qualification
qualifications that they know you've got
so yeah they might look at it in that
sense so they check your GCSE results
relative to the average GCSE results of
your school so if everybody in your
school's leaving with 10 DS and you get
to a stars that's going to look better
than if you get 9 f stars but everything
else in your schools graduating would
say 10 oh yeah but equally that's not to
say that if you went to a really good
school and you've got loads of a stars
and so did everyone else that's not
going to hinder your chances yeah okay
next question
there's Oxbridge consider you taking
Latin and does it give you an advantage
over other applicants I suppose yeah if
it counts as an a-level great they made
you know I don't know if you're gonna do
it do they do you like it well they do
classic Catholic yeah if you're a bunch
of classics yeah that's kind of a much
be helpful yet and maybe for medicine
but I don't I don't know that's point
out they're not going to specify that
you study Latin for
and clients even specifying if anything
other than classics but check the
website on that because I'm not really
sure
well the oxford website has the
recommended a levels but every course
they offer so like so it will tell you
which subjects you definitely have to
have and which subjects it's
advantageous to have so definitely check
out for any other subject like if you do
Latin if you're apply for English and
you do laughter that's someone else's
like English and they haven't done it
it's not you know it won't really make a
difference because it got a bit of very
aware that not all schools offer Latin
it's comparing apples and oranges yeah
it's just it's another a level it's
another language it's the same as doing
French I suppose and my time said unless
it's for classics where it would be
useful it's not going to have any grand
significance yeah exactly yeah so the
next one is is it true that interviewers
ask three weird questions like why do
teachers have spots or how many camels
are there in France I think what often
happens with interview questions is that
what the teachers will do is are styled
with a relatively normal question and
then they will escalate the complexity
so I can't think an example it's on the
head but what happens is that people
then walk away with the last part of the
question yeah
which can seem impossible this yeah this
is classic from interviews people come
out and say oh my god they asked me this
and taken out of context it's like yeah
well I know how do you even go about
answering that but if you're applying to
do biology and you're talking about like
camouflage and then they say why don't
you just have spots you know then that's
quite a sensible question in the context
of that conversation and like Alan
Turing how many camels are there in
France like if you're talking about I
know some obscure maths problem or some
kind of
I don't know thought game it's it's
rather way you think yeah exactly like
they may sound really random and really
weird out of context but in the
interview they won't make sense yeah I
mean so that we get the how many cameras
are in France that's probably going to
be like you'd have to estimate work had
to make assumptions like camels only
live in zoos then say how many zoos
there are in France and then how many
cameras they're like yeah you know it's
it's not they're not expecting you to
know how many zoos there are in France
or how many how many cameras are on but
they're looking for you to do that kind
of logical thought processes well I
wonder how many zoos are on let's say we
could work it out how many kind of thing
yeah you probably work it out like how
many in this country versus many near
meters one zoo is probably bout a
million people that live near me so if
there's 80 million people live in France
that's probably 80 series yeah and then
if there's five cameras per see you say
I've done that's yeah those your eyes
okay yeah by my boy but the questions
are going to be challenging um and they
may be obscure them they're going to be
things that you've never thought about
before you're not going to go in and be
asked everything that was on your a
levels of the most meal ID so this one
then yeah they're going to be different
but they're designed to make you think
so it's the way you approach them rather
than you know the explicit answers you
give that they'll be the important thing
is to talk out loud whilst Johnson
because they're not they're free don't
care about your arm so they care about
how you answer yeah and if you if you
get a question like that like yeah how
many cameras are in France you go oh my
god I have no idea they're not going to
say okay thank you like off you go
they're going to say well how would you
go about estimating it and they might
you know they're going to help you along
because they won't like like I said they
want you to do well so they're gonna
they're gonna kind of give you hints and
like push you a lot until you start
getting on the right
as a nice question I'm pretty sure it's
just a myth but there's a general
opinion that Oxford slash Cambridge well
that's like he's taking if you're from
North and the South of England is there
any truth to that how many no learners
do you know at Oxford okay so first of
all no that's not true
very they don't well they take into
account where you're from but only in
the sense of a they might look at kind
of what like what background yeah this
is so there's a red flag system so if
you apply from a particular postcode
they'll have a list of postcodes which
and I think it's like unknown force poor
academic performance or something like
that and so or lower household income
yeah so if I were raised if you're
something he applies from this base
codes
yeah and then though you're more likely
to get an interview certainly yeah but
so yeah the flagging process is prior to
interview so the fact that you're from a
lower-income family or your own an area
that doesn't send many people to Oxford
that's not going to get you a plate so
for someone who has the same grade as
you but it will increase your chance of
getting interview yeah and in terms of
the north/south divide I mean you have
to remember that a lot more people live
in the south than in the north so I do
know a lot of northerners are object in
our Bo club captain so I expert
sometimes it's like it they can't get
rid of them and also it's it's the
number of applications like it might
just be the fact that more people from
the South apply to Oxford like maybe
people from the north don't apply as
much and that's maybe an issue in itself
but within the admissions processes
their bias towards whether you're from a
normal doctor thing